[Music]  what kind of questions can science not  currently answer and may never be able  to answer yeah  is there an intelligence out there  that's underlies the whole thing you can  call them with the G word if you want I  can say are we a computer simulation  with a purpose is there an agent an  intelligent agent that underlies or is  responsible for the whole thing  does that intelligent agent satisfy the  laws of physics does it satisfy the laws  of quantum mechanics is it made of atoms  and molecules yeah there's a lot of  questions and I don't see this it seems  to me a real question  it's an answerable question well I'm  answerable the questions have to be  answerable to be real some philosophers  would say that a question is not a  question unless it's answerable this  question doesn't seem to me answerable  by any known method but it seems to me  real  you